F: Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec mon pote Rénald Zapata, c'est Monsieur Zapata. Et Zapata il fait quoi dans la vie?
F: Il peint.
Il peint très vite du coup tu es un?
Z: Speed Painter
F: Et ouais mais en même temps tu connaissais déjà la réponse
Z: Et oui forcément
*rires*
Z: C'est plus facile
F: Il vient souvent aux plateaux les allusions collectives et autres illusions fantastiques que je fais au grand point virgule
Le prochain c'est le 22 février, il y en a une le 28 mars où tu seras là
Z: Exactement
F: Et à chaque fois je demande au public de me donner un thème ou une personnalité ou quelque chose et Rénald doit le peintre
le plus rapidement possible
l'autre fois ça a duré 2h
on a pas reconnu à la fin c'était un moment très gênant
du coup comme tu es peintre
J'ai pensé à essayer de te faire faire un petit dessin.
alors voici l'idée tu vas prendre ce calepin, tu fais (bon y'a des trucs d'écris mais c'est pas trop grave)
tu fais un petit dessin dessus.
Z: Ouais
F: un truc simple hein je suis pas peintre moi
tu arraches la feuille, tu refermes le carnet
et tu me redonnes tout ça
Ça marche
Z: Ça marche
J'arrache la feuille? et je la garde...?
F: Oui tu l'as garde pour toi
F: pour toi euh...
Z: Je la garde dans une poche?
F: Oui dans une poche
Z: D'accord
F: Euh faut pas que je le vois donc peut-être tourne toi et moi je les regarde pendant ce temps là
Z: Faut que je fasse un dessin
F: Un dessin, pas un truc trop compliqué d'accord
Z: D'accord, ben écoutes on va faire euh...
F: Vous n'entendez que le son de ma voix
et vous regardez le MentalVlog
et tu t'abonnes
à cette chaîne YouTube
sinon j'ai l'impression d'être tout seul et qu'il y a que ma mère qui regarde
Ouais je sais pas si vous saviez mais vous pouvez vous abonner en cliquant sur le petit logo que je met dans la vidéo
F: Tu as fini c'est ça? Cool
Z: Ouais ouais mais vite fait
F: Tu as rebouché, tu as arraché la feuille, tu as refermé le carnet tout bon?
Z: Tac voilà
Z: On ferme le carnet
F: Ah suspense parce que j'ai pas encore expliqué ce que j'allais essayer de faire
F: Super. Ce que je vais essayer de faire c'est de retrouver le maximum d'éléments de ton dessin
Je ne vous promet pas de retrouver le dessin mais un maximum d'éléments
Ma 1ère question, j'ai une question d'abord
C'est: Est ce que c'est un objet?
Z: Non
F: C'est pas quelque chose que... physiquement attrapable et palpable
F: ah ça c'est embêtant pour moi
*rires*
F: Tu vois comme quoi tu es un peintre.
Quand je fais ce genre d'expérience sur quelqu'un à chaque fois il dessine un objet, quelque chose du quotidien
et ça m'aide beaucoup pour le retrouver
mais toi c'est abstrait que ça?
Dommage
Euh... est ce que tu peux t'imaginer que ton dessin est ici
ici juste ici
Z: Ouais
F: Ouais et que avec mon doigt je...  joue avec les formes que tu as fait
Z: D'accord
F: Essaie de trouver des choses à...
Y'a un arrondi c'est ça?
Z: Ouais joli
F: D'accord ok. Ça je l'ai.
J'ai des pistes d'idée, je vais les dessiner et alors ce qui est cool c'est que vous allez pouvoir juste voir en même temps que moi ce que je dessine
et ça c'est rigolo
euh...
Moi j'ai une espèce d'arrondie ici, donc je vais le dessiner là
petite confirmation ou infirmation. Est ce que jusqu'ici ça va?
Z: *ri* J'hallucine juste ça j'hallucine
F: C'est vrai?
F: Ok donc c'est une très bonne piste pour moi. euh...
Tu m'as dit que c'est pas un objet donc faut pas que j'aille du côté des verres, des lampes, des choses comme ça, des champignons. Euh...
En tout cas ça prendrait cette espace là à peu près
Z: Ouais ouais
F: C'est pas trop mal?
Z: Ouais c'est très très bien.
F: Ok bon je vais essayer d'aller jusqu'au bout du dessin à ma manière.
Et du coup
je vais essayer un truc comme ça
c'est tellement dégueulasse ce que je fais
*rire*
Z: Non mais je ne me suis pas appliqué non plus je te rassure
F: Écoute, j'arrache la feuille. Voici ce que j'ai dessiné. Est ce qu'on peux comparer avec ton dessin.
Z: Ben écoute,
F: Vu ta tête je sais que j'ai juste
Z: Ouais ben ouais
Voilà, je crois qu'on est quand même pas mal quoi
F: *Ri* je vous jure c'est une danseuse que j'ai fait. C'est une danseuse ça? sur pointe en tutu
Z: Ouais ouais. Voilà
Z: Exactement
F: Ah je suis ravi
F: Bon vous voyez que même en une seconde, il speed plus que moi et c'est beaucoup plus joli que moi
Merci mon Zapata. C'est mortel
Z: Tiens cadeau je te le signe
F: Vous savez même pas combien ça vaut ça
Z: Maintenant ça vaut cher, c'est signé
F: Sans signature ça vaut rien, avec ça... tu es le roi du pétrole
Z: Tu peux t'acheter un carambar
F: Je te le signe
Z: Voilà
F: et avec ça tu t'achète la serviette pour t'essuyer après le carambar
Z: Super
F: Retrouvez Zapata et toutes ces créations, il en poste souvent. Il fait aussi du Street art pleins de choses sur twitter @zapata_painter
rejoignez le. Vraiment c'est ta petite bouffée de plaisir au quotidien
Abonne toi à cette chaîne YouTube.
Suis Monsieur Zapata_painter.
RDV demain 17h pour le prochain MentalVlog. Ciao!